there used to be this goal within the
trans community of like an integration
into society and it's the exact opposite
now now it's this adversarial
relationship and it's a movement that
poses a threat to women and children now
which I don't think any movement that
even is perceived that way yeah can
survive well I I think you know thinking
on a deeper level in my own personal
opinion the last few years there was a
psychological emotional and physical war
against men and I think that war was
very successful and it destroyed manhood
masculinity testosterone sperm levels
you name it the modern man has been
pretty much subjugated and destroyed now
I think the agenda is moving up towards
women and I think the same thing is
happening to women right now and we're
seeing the early phases of this larger
psychological mental physical and and uh
emotional attack that they're going
through do you think one solution Luke
might be that men should sunbathe their
testicles uh well you got to be careful
giving too much heat on your balls
because it's actually bad this is a
Tucker Carlson reference